[Music]
chuck hey
you ever been in orbit
okay no the answer is no
[Laughter]
i'll answer for you okay you know i was
uh i was just thinking about a couple
nights where i partied really hard man
and
party down yeah so but of course not yes
okay so i wanna just tell you a little
bit of the history
of orbitz it's just for me it's
fascinating i don't know if you'll find
it fascinating okay but it's fascinating
to me
and it's my show so i get to do
you get your own show you can edit this
out okay
all right
so isaac newton
i'm a man all right he was around in the
1600s early 1700s okay he a an english
scientist physicist
natural philosopher they recalled back
then
deep deepest thinker i've ever known
i've ever read
on all of the operations of nature okay
and he's sitting there
and sees an apple fall
from an apple tree in his backyard in
lincolnshire which isn't very outskirts
of
um uh london
oh sorry i have cambridge but it's it's
in the in the countryside of england
okay okay it's it's a childhood home
where he grew up there's an apple
orchard there all right
did i tell you i was gifted a clipping
from that tree
uh i actually saw the tree you saw the
tree oh okay yes yeah i actually saw the
tree okay yeah that was a whole other
thing we got to dig that out of the
archives
i saw the sapling it is it was it was a
sapling yeah i saw the sapling which by
the way is still being cared for
uh at the new york botanical garden
gardens up in the bronx
so yeah okay so he's there and he sees
an apple fall to the earth didn't hit
him in the head that's just tail
and in the sky is the moon
okay
so
he thinks to himself
is there some way to connect
the falling apple with the orbiting moon
is there some
single understanding
that renders these two things that i'm
looking at
the same
most people would look at it and say
well there's something different going
on in the moon than for the apple
because the apple landed on earth on the
ground right and then the moon is not
falling
it stays up okay so clearly it's
different
but we're talking about isaac newton
and so he said
let's do an experiment
a thought experiment
let's go to a mountaintop
and
take the apple
and just sort of drop it
okay it'll follow the ground to the
earth the way it does in his backyard
but now let's sort of fire it from a
cannon
at ever increasing speeds so you do this
horizontally so you do this it'll fall
farther and farther away from you that
makes sense right right so the faster it
ejects from the cannon the farther it
will go well just keep doing this
exercise
and you keep doing it and the apple
starts following the curvature of the
earth
and it can and and maybe it falls a
thousand miles away but then hits the
ground well how about if it make it
faster how about
10 000 miles away and it hits the ground
well let's keep doing this
oh my gosh is there a speed
where i can eject it so fast
that it goes entirely around the earth
and hits me in the back of the head
boomer apple
and wait a minute
if there is such a speed
and it's about to hit me in the back of
the head and i duck
then it will just continue
nice so he said there must be such a
speed
and so he invents the laws of gravity
and then calculus and all this and he
figures out
that speed
and that speed for earth is about five
miles per second
wow if you go
sideways
neglecting air resistance and if you go
that's why you have to get high enough
where there's no atmosphere then you can
go sideways at five miles a second if
you go five miles a second sideways
that's about 17
500 miles an hour
then you're actually falling to earth
at exactly the rate that the curve of
the earth
curves away from you
right
so
to drop an apple is for the apple to be
in free fall
but to send an apple into orbit
is also to be in free fall right it's
just falling around the earth well no no
it's falling towards the earth right but
the earth has a curve and it never
actually hits them so i'm saying it's
right or that would be orbit what i just
described correct okay
so
the falling apple and the orbiting moon
are identical
the moon just happens to have a sideways
velocity that the apple did not that is
okay
all right and that's why astronauts are
weightless right they're not weightless
because they are in space they're
weightless because they are in free fall
towards earth in an orbit first
described by isaac newton in 1687.
wow
dude that first of all
i have a new respect for isaac newton
because for you to look at an apple
and say anything other than
i think it's lunchtime
and then take that apple and equate it
to a celestial body that orbits us
the moon itself
i don't even know how you get to there
yeah demand is hot at every time you
think about what he said what he thought
what he calculated he goes higher and
higher and higher on a scale of and by
the way
he there's a there's a plaque to him in
the chapel at university of cambridge
and there's a statue and it's in latin
and i loosely translate the latin it
says of all humans there is no greater
intellect
wow there's a loose translation that's a
deliberate statement
but it's
the smartest man in the world
i'm saying i i more i read about it yeah
yeah i'm with yes
yes i'm going with this yes
so so that's what an orbit is and that's
why
you are weightless in space and i think
we talked about this before but now it
has context there's a recent movie
what's that movie that had like moon
pirates on it um oh god yes at astra
right astra ad astra yes okay had there
were a lot of scenes where okay it took
the astronauts three days to get to the
moon because what they do is that they
get to five miles per second
going in orbit around the earth now they
want to escape the earth you have to go
faster
so you add another two miles per second
to your speed
you hit seven miles per second and now
earth will no longer hold you and you
escape the earth that's the escape
velocity that'll get you to the moon you
can coast to the moon at that speed all
right the astronauts were weightless on
route to the moon because they were
falling towards the moon
all right in ad astra they're always
firing their rocket oh it took them
three days to get there and at aster you
can get you can get to the moon in three
hours if you wanted to you just have to
fire your rockets right you're not gonna
but then you're not in free fall to the
moon right if you're firing your rockets
you have gravity artificially created by
the rockets inside your inside your uh
your vessel
right as long as your rockets are
burning you will feel that acceleration
and it is as though you created creates
like a gravity it creates like a source
of gravity and all the scenes where
they're firing their rockets everybody's
floating inside their space they got
that wrong they got it wrong plumb wrong
because they think being in space equals
being weightless and speaking of newton
that makes sense because you are the
reaction to the action of the rocket
being pushed you were now against it
correct there you go
that oh man if it's your reaction to the
action is the manifest it's manifested
as your weight as as as your weight and
kind of artificial gravity and by the
way
i like that movie thanks for ruining
that for me
so anyway i just want to make it clear
what's going on if you want to think
about space as being a place where you
are weightless it is only so because we
drift to our destination you don't run
your so when you're in orbit you don't
need rockets to sustain orbit
you just duck every time you come past
isaac newton's head all right and you'll
just keep and so in order to come out of
orbit here's the difference now to come
out of orbit
you have to fire some kind of retro
rocket to slow yourself down yeah okay
and as you slow down you can't maintain
that orbit you drop to a lower elevation
and eventually start hitting atmosphere
and then the atmosphere drags you down
to earth wow but how about that very
high speeds that you have that's kinetic
energy you got to dissipate that somehow
you need heat shields
we did a whole show on heat shields yeah
that was pretty cool okay yeah you need
those heat shields to disappear in
layers that come with you remember chuck
your good memory check so you you ablate
the heat shield this eats up your
kinetic energy that you had for going 17
500 miles an hour yeah atmospheric
breaks breaks it's aerobraking is
exactly what it is yeah so that means
any spaceship that you where all you did
was go up above the
the the you know the the atmospheric
line
into quote space and then come back to
earth
you don't need heat shields because you
didn't go 18 17 18 000 miles an hour
exactly you don't need heat shields you
just so it's a completely different
design of rocket
to do a sub-orbital thing with and land
as an airplane right as it does going
into orbit the shuttle pulled that off
the shuttle landed on a runway but it
also went into orbit because it had
wings and it landed like an airplane but
it also went into orbit how do you get
out of orbit you need heat shields it
had heat shields it's the entire belly
of the shuttle
the entire is heat shield
of a new generation than the onion peel
from the apollo era
this is a special silicate material
where i've played with it in a
laboratory oh my gosh
you can take a wafer of it take a blow
torch
blow torch it until it's glowing red hot
right and in the time it takes you to
put the torch back down
and you go back to it it's cool to the
touch it's already cool wow
that's pretty cool it's brilliant piece
of material to have a pair of oven mitts
like that
[Laughter]
okay
so
um so the shuttle so that's why the
shuttle had this very complicated design
and it took the government money and
nasa to pull that off nice um yeah
all right so before we go
what is right now i'm reading i'm
reading the uh
uh life of uh ulysses s grant because a
friend of mine loves grant
right so i said all right let me see
what all this hype is about so what's a
good book to read about your man
newton or do you have any suggestions
oh well there's a lot
there's a lot of books there's an
interesting one newton the last
alchemist or the last sorcerer because
he was really big into alchemy
he was the transition between old world
science and modern science basically
and
uh he did he penned more words on
alchemy than he did on physics for
example he was also deeply religious and
he wrote more on analyzing chronologies
in the bible okay because he has a whole
book called chronologies of ancient
kingdoms amended all right where he's
thinking about the bible and god and
jesus and the trinity and it was the
trinity real and well you know because
the anglican church and the catholic
church and and so there's all this other
stuff that he did i'm only talking about
his science so he's a very complex
figure plus he he never had any
romances of any kind that anybody has
ever been able to figure out so he has
no descendants we think he died a virgin
actually
oh wow
that's how
are you kidding me
no wonder he could look at an apple fall
and be like i wonder how this relates to
the
moon that boy never even thought about
it
you know how much i would think of if i
never thought about sex are you kidding
me where would he be sitting here right
now
be like nobel prize laureate chuck nice
five-time nobel prize exactly once again
has come up with a design for oh kidding
me the guy what okay who knew this
all right all right go ahead newton oh
yeah there's another book newton's
philosophy of nature
where they hand they cherry pick his
best stuff and they talk about it um
and uh i think bernard cohen i think is
the author of one of them and uh there's
another one written by an astrophysicist
a nobel laureate himself uh subrahmanian
chandrasekhar
who wrote a book on isaac newton and
it's like the principia companion so
noon's famous book is the principia
where he discovers gravity and and and
and all this and this is sort of a
uh an analysis of that book you get to
bask in his genius so there's a few
books out there all right cool i like
the last one but you know his real
handiwork is our modern understanding of
the universe absolutely yeah yeah maybe
just read the book of nature itself and
you're reading newton
wow you really like this guy
[Laughter]
all right calling it quits there thanks
for always being there chuck always a
pleasure
all right neil degrasse tyson for star
talk
keep looking up
[Music]
you